once you have the perspective that life
is dance
you'll begin to see dance everywhere
around you all day long like I do when I
choreographed for film television or
commercials I often generate moves that
are based on The Human Experience I take
these moves and I stream them together
twist and play with your pace in order
to create more meaningful work here's a
music video Chandelier that I
choreographed for Sia featuring The
Incredible dancer Maddie Ziegler
and Fork Fork Fork stabbed in the wall
toss it and pass out come to and look
Charlie Chaplin Charlie Chaplin
cockroach up the wall cleaned your
mustache a possum sink
is it time for lunch yet I'd love to
invite you to be your own choreographer
and let fun and laughter push the
boundaries of Ridiculousness
who knows maybe brushing your teeth or
whisking at mac and cheese will become
your new favorite dance move